احتفظت مراكش باعداد من السياح الاجانب
الرافدين مغادره البلد بالرغم من اهتزاز
الارض مفضلين البقاء مع سكنتها
[موسيقى]
هكذا بدات اسواق وشوارع مدينه مراكش بعد
ايام قليله فقط من الزلزال الذي ضرب
البلاد وكانها تشد من عزيمه قاطنيها لتخطي
الفاجعه ما تزال العديد من المرافق
السياحيه تفتح ابوابها للسياح الاجانب
وتقدم خدماتها لمن بقي فيها بعد الزلزال
الاجانب ليسوا فقط سياحا موسميين بل هناك
فئه تقيم بشكل دائم في المدينه التي
احتضنت الجميع واختاروها دون مدن العالم
الاخرى لقضاء اوقاتهم وحتى التملك والعيش
في مراكش الغنيه بتراثها وجمالها
[موسيقى]
وتشير الارقام الى ان عائدات قطاع السياحه
المغربي بلغت في النصف الاول من عام 2023
نحو 5 مليارات دولار مقابل 2.7 مليار
دولار عام 2022
[موسيقى]
زوينه تقليديه
المعماري والعمراني لمدينه مراكش له خصائص
كبيره
ولا يختلف مع الخصائص العامه لاي مدينه
ولاي نسيج عمراني عتيق واصيل
المكونات هما نفس المكونات الاساس هو
الانسان كيما كتعرفوا النظاره الخلدونيه
هي التي تسريع على جميع المدن الاصيله
والمدن العتيقه ديالنا في المغرب انه
المدينه العتيقه كانت فيها بعض المباني
الايه للسقوط وهذه مساله جد طبيعيه لان
كان هناك برنامج وطني برنامج ملكي باش
احنا باش يكون الترحيل هاد الاسر وهدم
هاته المباني الاله للسقوط قبل الزلزال
واعاده بنائها على الطراز المعماري الاصيل
بزاف ديال المسائل هناك اضرار من طبيعي
جدا هذا الزلزال ماشي عاصفه هذا زلزال
طبيعي جدا ان هناك بعض الاضرار
[موسيقى]
ما يزال الرهان صعبا حتى تستعيد مراكش
الوجهه التي يقصدها عدد كبير من السياح
الاجانب عنفوانها ورونقها وتعود لحالاتها
الطبيعيه بعد ان تضررت وانهارت بعض
مبانيها في المدينه القديمه المصنفه منذ
عام
1985 على لائحه التراث العالمي لليونسكو
[موسيقى]